there we go hello welcome back to
GameSpot's coverage of e3 2015 it would
not be an e3 if my boy Lucas thought I
didn't turn up talk to me if I'd
skylanders how you doing my friend good
for three years in a row a dick I think
we got a good Street going yeah it's
great a more skyline their supercharged
yeah fifth fifth this is relative can I
name all five I don't know can you [ __ ]
a mom mursel was just like spyro's
adventure yeah Pyro's added a question
out of it what's hot there he's from
clearpass fire am trap team oh you're
jumping and well or Giants yeah that was
to trap team yeah oh come on Soph force
yes yes there you go and buy the drive
and the supercharged skyliner
superchargers because there wasn't
officership with charges that's right I
knew all the other one on and I got the
new one raw and I'm looking at this
stuff we'll talk about this a little bit
this is madness what's going on vehicles
now yes yeah so what we're doing this
year is we're actually mixing our
traditional on foot combat with brand
new vehicle gameplay but we didn't just
want our vehicles to be kind of just
things you hopped into go from point A
to point B they're actually an integral
part of the experience and we've got
exploration we've got combat we've got
puzzle solving all within the confines
of land sea and sky based vehicle
gameplay seamlessly with our on foot
gameplay excellence let's check it out
you've got it set up right here already
yeah absolutely so we've got a couple
characters that we're showing for the
first time here at e3 I've got Fiesta
and the crypt crusher mmm and so what
we've got this year are 20 supercharger
skylanders and then we've also got 20
vehicles okay and so as I mentioned
we've got land sea and sky based
vehicles and so crippled and base
vehicle but the reef river here is sea
and sky slicer here is sky yeah and so
you can see another thing that we're
doing this year is these toys don't have
bases yes these are full blown vehicle
today like you can wrote like a here to
get rolled onto the heels you can roll
this is my favorite I call this the
eggbeater I like that
that's very good you get the propeller
to turn like this so the action here the
fin flipper that thing and so
design-wise sorry that's all right it's
all right toys so design-wise where it
makes sense we wanted to actually give
these an added bit of life an added bit
of additional articulation for the first
time so for us it's been a lot of fun
because traditionally in all of our toys
the life video games it's been really
character focused yeah big time and so
this time pushing that boundary to go to
the vehicle side of things has been a
lot of fun excellent let's talk about
the gameplay we've got we've got some of
it showing up here looks great first of
all I know you guys are you guys kind of
support all of the breadth of consoles
and we're looking at the ps4 stuff here
yeah yeah yeah I mean we we actually are
designing the game from kind of the
ground up on the newest generation of
platforms really pushing our visuals I
mean our team of vicarious visions are
basically tech Wizards yeah I mean those
guys push graphics like you know you
haven't seen and then it's also scalar
because this is coming out on the wii as
well yeah yeah it's it's coming out on
just about every everything you can
imagine really Amy yeah we got 3ds Wii
Wii U ps3 ps4 x 360 xbox one and iPad
crazy and iPad as well yeah so last year
we did with trap team was we actually
introduced the entire game on an iPad we
had this really cool portal and
controller that we gave you and
basically turned your ipad into a TV
screen that you could take anywhere and
play the full experience and so do all
like the other four games did they still
work on the new one every single
character that we have ever created
works in our game how many what what are
we talking like a little lately every
hundred 23 or yes it's madness but do
you know them all no I mean I do and if
you if you showed it to me I can name
every one but yeah sitting here doing
all three hundred I no no don't worry
i'm so used to swap you straight up
swapped ahead to a flight base yeah
exactly so you can see here my buddy
Sean is is playing through our sky based
sequence and when you're in the sky
you've got that added sense of mobility
you've got the Edit sense of movement
and right here it's more of a track
focused forward chase sequence where
you're trying to take out these
transport ships but even level by level
we're opening up what we can do with
these different types of vehicle
gameplay let's go here can you just get
out whatever you want as well no it's in
a specific sequences yeah okay so it
goes from on foot to vehicle but in this
sequence like I said we're going more
forward you know kind of track base but
in other levels we've got full 360
degree dog fighting we even have a level
where the cameras top down and you're
going old school arcade scene you know
you dodge the bullets and we do that for
land and sea as well and so making sure
that these vehicle sequences have as
much variety that we've been able to put
in our on foot gameplay these aren't
just you know added one-off types of
encounters it's a fully fledged
experience excellence let's talk about
the ape in the room yeah mr. Donkey Kong
yeah is that right beside us here and I
just Bowser yeah can I can I show off
like what I think yeah who does feel
absolutely yeah we get a camera on this
bad boy yeah first of all these guys
look obstacle you got you to a
partnership with Nintendo yeah perhaps
the coolest thing is right under here it
says it what's it say there today
skyline there's Skylander if you flip it
it says amiibo yeah trust me in there so
you can just straight up just click it
like that Miss amiibo yeah basically
these guys are our Skylanders guest
stars with a MIMO functionality to bring
a I don't know but they also have their
own exclusive vehicles and so it's been
really great as working with Nintendo
collaborating with them on creating
these characters into the game they work
in the wii u the wii the 3ds versions of
the game and they have so much insane
history with them as they fly off into
your pocket i mean you can even see on
the vehicles themselves we've put a lot
of history like Donkey Kong's this is
barrel blaster and what's my favorite is
that it's marrying the two kind of key
moments for Donkey Kong his original
introduction where he threw his barrels
and his mine cart which is so iconic
with Donkey Kong Country yes and then
for the clown Cruiser which is Bowser's
vehicle it's got the clown face paint
okay from super mario world which was
his boss fight in that gyrocopter and
then the armor plating is that of the
Koopa shells you know it's awesome and
so when you play as these guys each one
is full of so much history and the teams
actually put that into their move sets
because we've created them as
skylanders they play like nothing you've
ever played with either of Donkey Kong
or Bowser in fact one of the cool things
is that we're actually the first ones to
bring Bowser into a 3d action game
already has never been in a 3d action
game I got tropical freeze yeah okay
never too d yeah yeah he's pretty engine
but I mean well you know what I mean
like I've never actually been in a 3d
action event that's great are you going
to do more stuff with Nintendo is this
like the tip of the iceberg I mean we'll
see I mean I think fans are really
excited about this I know I'm really
excited about it I can't stop playing
with Donkey Kong and so we'll just see
where we go from there I textin I think
I think this was a super clever little
happen work both ways yeah it's they
look great I think the fact that these
moves speaks volumes as well because
yeah like what this has always been I
guess choice alive and you guys were
where you guys were starting kicking
this whole thing off you know now it's
leaving me bows and obviously Disney
infinity and when you guys started doing
this the idea that these were toys that
worked in games they weren't just pieces
of plastic that changed the video game
yeah and your fan base obviously has
grown it's been five years of doing our
five games ya doing skyline is much more
seven or eight years at this stage and
have you felt it like almost like a lot
of games of that nature like Harry
Potter i always think those games
evolved with their audience because
their audience got older and you guys
when you're envisaging this stuff are
you creating games for that growing
audience or are you trying to like grab
sort of stay with your you're like 18
set I mean that's actually a really good
question and something we kind of look
at both I mean for us we don't want to
you know abandon the fans that made the
games what they are but at the same time
we want to make sure that we get new
people to experience the game and so
it's kind of that perfect balance that's
why we fully respect the collection
every year and bring you know the whole
collection forward so fans can continue
their adventure with their favorite
characters but at the same time we have
to ensure that straight out of the box
we're creating a captivating game that
is fun for anyone for the first time and
for people to play with others as well
yes I said local co-op and whatnot yeah
we we always support our drop in drop
out co-op this year is actually really
fun because we've kind of changed it up
for the vehicles and so in on foot
sections up Shawn's waiting for me for a
land vehicle sorry Sean sorry
but in in in on foot sections you have
both your skylanders but then when you
get to a vehicle section you actually
assume the role of kind of a driver in a
gunner and so you're in the same vehicle
together each doing different things and
you can press a button at any time to
switch between who wants to drive and
who wants to use the attacks and so
we've seen with us playing it as well as
kids playing the game is that you see a
lot of fun kind of focus where someone's
focusing on strafing around an enemy
doing doughnuts around them I have a
drift button in a land vehicle while the
other ones focused on trying to aim and
collect our gear bits which are our
vehicle currency and so you can see here
we're in a land vehicle section and so
Sean's kind of speeding down the
highways of our cloud Kingdom level he's
got his his his minions his fiesta
minions in tow riding on the back of his
vehicle and one of the things that's
interesting is you'll notice the the
vehicle looks a little bit different
than the vehicle does on the portal yeah
it's [ __ ] blue wheel situation in
treta game yeah exactly so one of the
things that we've got is the ability to
customize your vehicle and so what we
want to do is kind of put a Skylander
spin on car tuning or vehicle tunic and
basically what that means is you're not
hopping onto the hood and fiddling with
spark plugs and knobs and switches what
you're doing is actually trading whole
parts out and so for each vehicle there
are two places that you can mod cool and
so on you see the Crypt crusher here
it's actually the main coffin body as
well as that back wheel decide stay with
the the local game save on the console
[ __ ] on the toy so if you bring that soy
to your buddies house your buds will be
a quick it's pretty cool and so the mods
are really cool because it allows you to
explore the world find different pieces
change the look of your vehicle very
very drastically but then get all the
benefits of tuning so you're changing
your your acceleration your top speed
you're handling in your arm or while
you're doing that awesome yeah we've
seen a lovely breadth of characters we
have here any chance we can stick one of
these bad boys in there so we're playing
on the playstation 4 version and so the
characters obviously these are Nintendo
guys yeah and so they're gonna work on
the wii u the we in the 3ds versions of
the game not going to ever get those on
to other platforms I it's a Nintendo
question now track that ain't up to lose
sutter thank you so much loop for coming
on
gori sure I look forward to seeing your
game with the sixth I'm see if we can
we'll keep doing this is good ten years
from now I'll be rattling at every
single year it's all good I don't know
why you guys are gonna do next thanks so
much for coming on I'd shown us the
latest content absolutely enjoy the rest
you III yeah you do cool and make thank
you for watching on gamespot com of
course on the YouTube III hub and if
you're watching on hitbox as well
welcome nice to have you today the
second day of the stage show right here
on III our gamespot's has stage and III
we got a bunch more stuff coming up next
up bit of a bit of a hard swing we got
dark souls 3 stay too